gary's doing this other annoying thing
he's um
working on a a family tree project
gary's training
his family tree and it's bothering me i
feel like there's part of my
grandparents that i don't know and
there's a couple of relatives alive who
still remember them
and know them and i'm trying to gather
that information just annoying to me i
don't know
i think if i do anything that's annoying
yeah i know why is that
i don't know here's the gary puppet
maybe he knows why gary puppet was
really annoyed
i don't know but i'm finding out amazing
results
i had one member of the family his name
was neanderthal de la batte
he was the first the first de la bate to
walk upright on his hind legs
right and then there was benito de la
bate he worked for benito mussolini
he loved chocolate music and falling
asleep on planes
while working with his ball
wow really it sounds like you're really
learning about your origins
and and then i had a circus relative his
name was harry de la batte
he was a wolf man in a circus is that
right
yeah did he make a good living he would
howl at the moon and he had very big
teeth
really well i could see where the big
teeth come from yes from harry delabotte
yeah
and then i had one relative her name was
hottie de la batte she was a hooker
oh my wow was she
very good at it very very good she did a
thing called the teeth job
men would pay extra for that wow
wow isn't that something that men like
that i guess yeah
so how far are you into this gary the
project is it going well
yeah i mean i've only gone but i think
i've gotten back to my great
great grandfather so far but i did find
out i mean this isn't like a huge thing
but it was kind of interesting to me
i live up here in connecticut i just
assumed that all my relatives they were
from italy and they lived in either
brooklyn or new york and i found out
that my great grandfather
lived in my town from like 1905 to 1920.
probably like three or four miles away
and i thought it was kind of interesting
to me oh i can't wait for the book
yeah there will be no there's another
book in you no i mean this is
interesting to me